[Musique]
simple à utiliser les cellules sous vide
permettent entre autres d'éviter le
gaspillage alimentaire en prolongeant la
durée de conservation des aliments
moi en tant que personne qui vit tout
seul j'achète un impact de 4 poitrine de
poulet je vais pas nécessairement les
manger les caps
la saleuse c'est tout méthodes de
conservation que je trouve intéressant
stéphanie grondin et blogueuse en
alimentation
nous lui avons demandé de mettre à
l'épreuve 4 c'est le sous-vide domi prix
varient de 95 à 150 dollars
l'appareil siro mire le cuisinart le
hamilton beach et son modèle de la
marque foot c'est vrai j'étais sa chose
moi je les ai amenés à noël pour tester
toutes les restes ans à venir pour le
temps trop bref pour noël et ont servi
cette année à tester des saleuses
question de comparer l'efficacité de ces
appareils à retirer l'air nous avons
emballé sous vide
dgo or qu'est ce qui va se passer avec
marc est ce que leur vaut partir du 18
août
par train de perdre notre kabylité
complète
mine de rien on voit mieux où il réside
d'ailleurs c'est fait le mieux les
gagnants fautes serveurs et hamilton
beach mais assurément le silo mille
gagne la palme du plus bruit
quand on fait l'amour il est important
de retirer le maximum d'air des sacs car
le plus grand ennemi de la conservation
des aliments
c'est l'oxygène des aliments est
présenté sous une seule conserve plus
longtemps parce qu'ils n'ont pas altéré
par l'air dans le fond qui viennent
orner les d'affairé par exemple la durée
de conservation du poulet peut passer de
6 mois à 2 3 ans une fois emballé sous
vide et congelés référez vous au tableau
de conservation des aliments offerts
seulement par deux compagnies
si le mur est fou de ses vins ces
appareils servent aussi à mariner
cuisine art et hamilton beach ont chacun
une fonction permettant de sceller des
aliments humides telles que ce poulet
mariné dans le même temps leurs un
humour de nacre naturelle
on est vraiment une poche dab étonnant
donc seul ce modèle de la marque
fuchs et beurre et le silo ben ils ne
font pas de différence entre les
aliments humides et secs la gare une
poche d'air on veut vraiment des bulles
d'air liquide
j'imagine que c'est pas pour de la
conservation c'est pour signer oui pour
m'amener au frigo par exemple tant elles
avaient ou pour 24 heures vous mettez ça
dans le frigo également une mine ce
système c'est ce que moi je dis qu'on
est si jamais trop de liquide est aspiré
mais il risque de se vider à l'intérieur
de l'appareil
dans la seconde c'est sûr c'est que le
liquide va aller couler dans ça ça nous
permet de laver la vaisselle
le silo 1000 et le footsie beurre sont
les deux modèles à avoir en ramasse
gouttes amovible pour avoir testé les
quatre machines
est ce que vous préférez avec un masque
ou tous arabes asbu ben honnêtement je
trouve que ça nettoie bien est ce que je
ferais plus cher une machine pour avoir
leurs amarres gouttes non
il est possible de nettoyer et
réutiliser ces anciens sacs
on s'est aussi demandé si c'était
possible de sceller un sac de plastique
commerciales à savoir impeccable ouais
c'est bon sens veut que ça tiers est-ce
que vous avez vu des grandes différences
entre c'est réparé mais en fait au
niveau qualité produire je dirais non
moi mon mépris les principales
différences je trouve dans le fait de
manipuler l'appareil
le modèle s'illumine termine dernier en
termes de facilité d'utilisation
tous vos besoins avec la pression des
mains faisait lié à va hélas je ne mens
jamais poster devoir appuyer quand même
fort sur la machine pour qu'elle
fonctionne et si vous aviez un modèle à
choisir ce sera bien choisir et la
footing
pourquoi célestin par fonctionne
facilement on tourne poignée manivelle
sur le côté qui va nous mettre à aulnoye
oft est assurément série que choisir
[Musique]